all right I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
nowhere to hide that's the focus of
tonight's angle
so we were all excited for what we
assumed would be an hour-long sit-down
interview rare for Joe Biden and prime
time tonight
but Jake Tapper a fairly friendly
interviewer was only able to get 15
minutes out of our 46th president of the
United States 15 minutes this was the
big exclusive
I mean that's hardly enough time to
cover Hunter and the hookers
well not to mention the foreign policy
mess we're in now with the Russia
Ukraine conflict
remember it was only late last week when
Biden was warning of nuclear Armageddon
he called it the worst risk since the 62
Cuban Missile Crisis but tonight Biden
gave a very different assessment of the
situation do you think Putin is a
rational actor
I think he is a rational actor who's
miscalculated significantly
but then Biden seemed to contradict
himself just moments later
I think the speech is okay his
objectives were not I think he thought
Jake I think he thought he's going to be
welcome with open arms that this was
this has been the home of mother shankiv
and and they were he was going to be
welcomed and I I think he just totally
miscalculated it right I I'm very
confused so Putin's a rational actor
with irrational goals how does that make
sense
so Biden's inability to provide a cogent
clear answer to an important question
that involves the safety of every living
American it's not just disastrous for
him politically
it's extremely disturbing not to mention
dangerous
no wonder the interview was cut so short
and to that point
CNN does have an obligation does it not
if there are any questions about this to
release the entire exchange with Biden
was any part of this interview edited
any questions off limits any
restrictions set by the white house
beforehand
Biden's very shaky exchange comes on the
heels of more terrible polling that was
just released numbers that point to
Democrats dimming chances of holding on
to power
now this was from Reuters tonight
Biden's approval numbers remain near the
lowest of his presidency just four weeks
until November's election day
in a new IMF report also just out spells
more bad news for America under Democrat
leadership
check this out for 2022 the IMF is
projecting that U.S growth will only hit
1.6 percent and for next year it gets
even worse
with the real GDP expected to be a
pathetic one percent
Administration just ignores the harsh
truth they're literally lying about how
things really are
from the perspective of the United
States I think the United States is
doing very well I remain encouraged the
U.S economy is strong we had an
employment report just last Friday that
shows we continue to have a very
resilient economy I don't think there
will be a recession if it is it'll be a
very slight recession okay they need to
hit the shuffleboard Court I mean I mean
America the truth is is facing a
prolonged period of economic Decline and
yet Biden's Wall Street backers they're
somehow just coming around to the idea
that some of his policies may have
spiked inflation
The pro-china globalists Wanted by
Dynamics and they got bidenomics the fed
and the government together gave an
enormous amount of debt and credit and
created a Lurch forward it a giant Lurch
forward and created a bubble okay and
now they're putting on the brakes okay
so now we're going to create a giant
Lurch backward
is that the sophisticated analysis Ray
Lurch backward what did he think would
happen
everything Biden said on the campaign
trail signal trouble printing money
borrowing money
and you're going to have this big fiscal
stimulation hey you're going to get a
lot of stimulation
during the 2020 campaign we heard the
same stunning lack of insight from
billionaire Larry Fink as well because
the BlackRock founder has two black eyes
one for pushing the idiotic and
destructive ESG agenda and another for
this post-election comment about Biden
they're looking for a voice that
moderates not a voice that incites I
truly believe
president-elect Biden can be that voice
of reason the marketplace is encouraged
by having a leader now that is more
inclusive a leader that could probably
bring a little more Global Harmony
okay how's that Marketplace looking for
you now Larry
or they call this
Global Harmony
yes Biden and his economic team of
dullards and dimwits were propped up by
Big Time by Wall Street
even the supposed reasonable Democrat
like Jamie dimon the CEO of JP Morgan he
got in on the ACT back in October of
2020 he took great comfort in the fact
that Biden was from Delaware which he
described as a pro-business state adding
that I'm hopeful Joe Biden has been
around the block he knows a lot of
people he's a compromiser a unifier in a
good way by Nature
well and what's Jamie saying two years
later
and this is serious stuff okay this is
inflation and it's the war and these are
very very serious things which I think
are likely to push the U.S uh and you
know the world I mean Europe is already
in recession then they're likely to put
us in some kind of recession
uh aren't diamonds supposed to shine
brightly be really clear well in 2020
Joe Biden was incapable of campaigning
I'm sure Jamie saw that
but when Biden did speak he mouiled the
platitudes of the left including all the
anti-oil and gas nonsense that we've
gotten used to
and yet Wall Street still backed him
they thought it was a good idea to put a
23 trillion dollar economy in the hands
of a daughter in goofball
they showered Biden and the Democrats
with huge campaign contributions I want
to be clear in making
that from my getting to know Believers
and I don't know she but I know that
those around them
that they are reasonable people I think
the longer term picture in China is
still bright because I know the people
and I know the culture and I think it's
good
they were either sucking up to China or
sucking up to Biden
well how long will it be before key
members of the plutocracy admit they
were wrong
because they deserve part of the blame
here because they gave Biden cover
the entire world economy is now being
flushed down the toilet our 401ks our
home values savings all down down down
it's going to be years before these
losses are made up and for many
Americans they may never see a positive
swing back in their lifetime
millions of Americans could lose their
jobs
so a lot of people owe America apologies
the media created the Biden wrecking
ball because they didn't really recover
them
and the Craven cads on Wall Street
funded him
it'll be up to all of us to take our
business and our votes elsewhere
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else